set back over by the charges three-ball
from Hillsdale Crowder hammers it in my
name is Ashley Carter I graduated in
2012 and I played volleyball for
Hillsdale College so I actually went to
a camp that was hosted at Hill so I'd
actually never heard of the school
before I remember doing a drill in the
middle of the afternoon and Chris Korbel
walked through the gym and I must have
caught his attention he actually got
ahold of me later that day and I came
back to his office and he kind of told
me what hills of college volleyball was
about and kind of about the campus and
the school I think I committed a Spring
Break of my junior year of high school
Hills oh truly is a home away from home
in a second I went on campus and did my
recruiting visit and meeting the team
and just some of the staff members it
was like it's cliche but the statement
it's the people couldn't be more true
about Hillsdale College my senior year
we were fortunate to host the regional
tournament and just the atmosphere with
the community and the students and the
other student athletes that came and
supported us those three days we ended
up winning fortunately but with their
love and support definitely helped us we
actually ended up being a University of
Indianapolis and then we went on to
California for the final floor and that
was definitely a memory I'll never
forget being on a team like that has
definitely influenced me to be able to
use past experiences whether it was
something to do with conflict or winning
or success it makes it easier on my job
to say that I've been there I've done
that I kind of get what you're going
through Schumacher he's set to Ashley
Crowder for 100 kills on the day 13-7
you learn every single day I learn in
the gym I learned through practice you
learn through failure you can't just
expect to go on the court or you know on
the field for any other sport and just
win you have to earn it it's not going
to be given and through failure so
through a loss you're able to take
something from that and use it in a
positive way my teammates like I would
not be sitting here getting inducted in
this Hall of Fame without them there
they pushed me they supported me they
made me a better player every single day
that we got in the gym together it's
truly an honor to join other people in
the Athletic Hall of Fame when I got
that call from Coach crevalle honestly
teared up for a little bit because it's
such a big accomplishment and I knew I
when I was going through college it's
something I was always trying to strive
or so being able to be inducted with all
these other past inductees and even the
people in my class this year it's truly
an honor and I'm extremely grateful
[Music]